good afternoon i'm mary ulrich with
quinoa cooperative extension in orange
county
i two am on the hemp team and i'm going
to address a little bit about risk and
reward because of course the question
this year is the reward of hemp the
potential for
profit balance out with the risk
because those two things should be in
direct proportion to one another but
they may not be
and so has hemp and all rainbows and
kittens or is it a little wild westy
i've seen a lot of wild westy out there
in the last couple of years
and so i'm going to address a couple of
ways to protect yourself
from the bad actors and other potential
negatives that
occur so how's risk measured and
mitigated you know we use
cost of production data john mentioned
that
it's coming along but the future market
certainly is questionable we certainly
do need more
of more interest from consumers to keep
that price up to keep the demand up
we also mitigate risk with crop
insurance i don't know what the payments
i haven't talked to anybody who
signed up for crop insurance and i mean
the usda
fsa crop insurance
so i don't know what those payments are
going to be for 2020.
my prediction last year was that they
were either going to be really good or
really bad
and so we'll see what happens with them
i'm always curious to talk to people
who've had insurance so if you've had
insurance please
give me a ring because private or the
federal government supported ones
that would be i'd love that information
so and also one way to protect yourself
or to
mitigate risk is to have a contract and
of course with the 2018
farm bill going to be brought into
effect in new york state
by the end of the year there's lots of
changes in the landscape happening and
of course we're not used to
legislation changing so quickly around
crops but the last few years this has
been
quite a little roller coaster so that in
itself is a risk that you don't know
where things are going to go
legislatively of course the big
force measure or the big risk is that
fda may decide to
regulate the crop particularly in the
case of cbd
and that could have a huge impact
on markets production if fda said no no
this
is a drug and everybody has to have
just like a drug everybody has to have
the same kind of testing and monitoring
then there would be a lot of producers
and processors
that would no longer have a market
because they couldn't meet those
requirements
and so the other thing i just want to
say about contracts you know if it
sounds too good to be
true it probably is and
i'm going to show you a flyer in a
minute that
can help you out in terms of contracts
so what's the biggest thing that i see
as a problem with uh hemp
contracts or hemp relationships right
now
is that there's no collective knowledge
you know we have for
produce we have the blue book so the
people can go look up buyers in new york
state
buyers are bonded so that if
a seller doesn't get paid they can go to
the state and get reimbursed through
that bonding process
if you know they really didn't get paid
for something that they sold and
everything was supposed to be okay and
the seller just didn't get their money
there's a way to get it back but in hemp
that doesn't exist right now
and there's no institutional memory
which we should have
or we have in other businesses you know
who is going to pay you you know who the
traditional bad actors are you know the
guys who pay in 30 60 90 and the ones
who don't
if you don't know your neighbors do and
so sharing information about that
in other crops has been very open and
hemp it has not been so even
what little institutional memory is
being gathered
it's not being shared and so it seems
like
bad actors are going from farm to farm
or from region to region
and causing trouble and certainly this
isn't just about cbd
i've had it happen that folks selling
grain came to me
because they didn't get paid for their
grain because the buyer said
that it was moldy but didn't tell it was
moldy until like three months later
so there's no way to trace back whose
fault that was it was just very
unfortunate and so also very unusual
relationships between
value and cost that the farmer needs to
buy
into the processing somehow which is
really you know not the case
ocean spray you know really doesn't need
the farmers necessarily
to buy into the processing part itself
they might be a co-op
in terms of selling but do they own the
equipment
maybe not or orange juice companies or
any of those
there isn't that same kind of need to be
involved
there's a lot of interest from people
who have never been involved in
agriculture
that can be a little bit of a problem
there's also what i call the billionaire
rule there's a lot of folks running
around saying oh i have billionaire
friends well unless you see a picture of
him with
warren buffett like on his christmas
card don't believe it
so uh one of the local growers actually
said if it's a good party it'll still be
going in a couple of years
and if it's a bad party i never wanted
to go in the first place
he said that one question about why he
was because he was going to grow and
then changed his mind in the last minute
and
19 and so just um using caution
so to try and um
look more closely at some of those
contract details there's this uh
six page pamphlet the first two pages
are about production stuff but then the
next four about contracts
i wrote it with the assistance of
several attorneys agricultural attorneys
and so uh just have a look at that it's
on both the cornell website
and the hemp blog which here's the pages
and so the blog is on the left
that's what it looks like and so there's
regular news updates there and
updates for meetings and things like
that there's also the link for the
contract thing
and on the right don't forget that
cornell has its own website
and then the team whether it's other
people you've heard from today
or john or lindsay or myself all of our
contact information is also on there on
the team website